well the FBI has now opened an
investigation into the Dayton gunman as
evidence emerges he previously expressed
a desire to commit a mass shooting
investigators also say Connor Betts had
a history of violent ideology steam
Reynolds's in Dayton and Dean it seems
like the Republican governor there has
some new proposals that's right but
first the FBI will be looking at three
main things what ideology may have
influenced the attacker who if anyone
helped him or knew of his intentions
beforehand and why he chose to commit
that specific act all of this comes as
the shooters parents have made their
first public statement late Tuesday
police delivered a statement on behalf
of Connor Betts parents it included an
expression of horror and grief over the
loss of both of their children they
asked that everyone respects the
family's privacy in order to mourn the
loss of their son and daughter
Connor Betts went on a 30 second rampage
in Dayton's Oregon district and in that
time he killed nine people including his
sister Megan before police shot and
killed him we have uncovered evidence
throughout the course of our
investigation that the shooter was
exploring violent ideologies I didn't
think he would go shoot strangers
especially his sister
Adelia Johnson the shooters
ex-girlfriend says they dated from March
to May Betts was studying psychology in
college and that's why at first she
didn't think much of his fascination
with violence he was interested in what
makes terrible people do terrible things
but looking back there were red flags on
their first date he showed her a video
of a mass shooting she broke up with him
in the spring I'm not shocked he did
something horrific
I am shocked that we are also learning
more about the victims Nikolas Kumar was
a graduate student study in cancer care
beatrice nicole warren curtis worked in
health insurance and friends say she was
always supportive thomas McNichols was
the father of
or children all ages eight and under
Dion Green says he was enjoying a night
out with his father 57 year old Derek
fudge when the shooter opened fire he
saved my life not there's no way that I
shouldn't been one that got hit his dad
died in his arms he's just staring at me
just staring I mean I'm just like come
on then he just he just thought he just
stops breathing him and I just I just
lose it I just grab him hold him just
tell him I love him just hold me now the
FBI says the shooter was not on its
radar before this incident and while
they are not saying what specific
ideology he may have embraced they are
saying they found no evidence that this
attack was racially motivated or
influenced by events in El Paso the day
before Anthony
Dean Reynolds thank you Dean